the Joe Rogan experience and we need an
equal word - come on son - two girls you
know I mean sister works we need I'm a
big fan of the friendly light come on ho
you know just in the friendly way I like
all girls hook when girls yell [ __ ] out
I settled down hooker yeah but it's all
it's not like in my day I feel like
you're the only person the only person I
mean that and I don't say that lately
that I'm like I can laugh when you're
like yeah [ __ ] mm right we did that and
the world show 2012 that was fun we did
a did a show at The Wiltern in Los
Angeles on December 21st 2012
that was the Terence Mckenna thing the
end of the Mayan calendar
he had a compute this out deep that
[ __ ] ran he got so high he came
up with an algorithm based on the each
hing that was mapping out time it wasn't
the Mayan calendar it was it was both
okay
who's the Mayan cattle T was based on
novelty it would coincided with this is
what happened he came up with a thing
called novelty theory and novelty theory
he based off to each Inge the II Ching
which is it's a divination system a
Chinese divination system and they would
throw these hexagrams I believe it's hex
crams and they would indicate a certain
pattern and they would try to recognize
this Pat was it hexagrams
anyway they would throw these thank you
so it's a Chinese method of divination
that's more than a thousand years old
and they were trying to conduct what
McKenna believed this is what he
believed me Ching really was he
believed it was a map of time and that
they had through some way figured out
through hexagrams to recognize a time
was it was mimicked about you could
capture it in in hexagrams in in in
mathematics and geometry it's like a
string theory kind of thing almost all
right and that you could come up with
some sort of a system to this thing and
he called that system time wave zero and
what he thought that system was he
thought that was a system of recognizing
novelty like new ideas creative things
whether it's the internet or internal
combustion engine or the Tesla electric
car anything where it was where you
could map that out and you could say
okay if you looked at this as a
mathematical algorithm and you saw how
this was gonna play out you could almost
predict patterns in this wave and where
do you where do you predict this
happening and that happening and where
does it end where does it get to a point
where it's so crazy no one knows what
the [ __ ] to do and in Terrance's life he
believed that time was December 21st
2012 and he as a matter of fact my
barracuda out of 1970 barracuda my my
license plate was December 2012 21st I
was like if I'm gonna die my favorite
people on the planet legitimately
through the countdown that's what I love
there was no like ten nine you're like
Happy New Year [ __ ] it was
great yeah it was fun it was fun it was
like my favorite people are my family
and my friends there's been yeah and to
be able to do a show and I wore a
[ __ ] suit yeah
if Odin's gonna come capture me he's
gonna capture [ __ ] very fine
david august apparel didn't Joey Diaz do
a set
don't Joey Diaz Doug Stanhope that was
so special for bringing us on it was fun
just me and Stanhope look I love
Stanhope as much I cut my [ __ ] pinky
off first and home but I don't see him
enough you know so whenever we gonna
make an excuse to do this we're gonna do
another I should tell this right now
we're gonna do another end of the world
podcast at the new presidential
elections so when was it November 21st
mm what is it like the first week the
first two first remember whatever it is
2020 we're gonna be at the Comedy Store
we're gonna make that [ __ ] happen we're
gonna do another live podcast this time
it's just gonna be me Stanhope and a
couple other people we last time we got
too many people November third end of
the world everyone even the people at
the top of government are just people we
all they need to listen to we all need
acid and we can work together this
soldat system that we're on this [ __ ]
clock that we're on it's not good for
anybody
yeah we're not worried no one's good at
being wrong no one's good at being like
oh I made a mistake I'm so sorry because
you're a human and that's what we do and
that's where I think there's this like
real disconnect with the people that are
quote unquote running this country you
know there's there's no room for error
it shouldn't be running it that's and
they know it that's why they're holding
onto that spot no one should be I think
they would do a better job running it if
they could exhibit human qualities and
also be leaders at the same time I agree
you know but I think they're scared I
think everybody's scared and I think
when you're in a position where here is
real angular what buying mind control
over giant groups of people you you
barely can keep your [ __ ] together like
who are you are you an alien
you have another [ __ ] planet you know
[Music]
take me to your leader dude remember
Close Encounters oh they talked to be
bull
[Applause]